bonsoir jean pierre merci merci d'être
avec nous alors une première réaction à
cette fusion entériné bonsoir oui bah
écoutez pour nous le le seul point
positif de cette fusion c'est cette
incroyable force qui est né de 2 400
mille salariés par delà les frontières
par delà les océans techniciens
ingénieurs cadres ouvriers ils
représentent une force qui va falloir
qu'elle cette force elle soit vraiment
consciente d intérêt qu elle à défendre
des intérêts communs qui elle à défendre
par delà les frontières
parce que vous savez cette fusion votre
reportage là en partie évoquée il est
certain que l'objectif des actionnaires
de psa et de fiat et d'augmenter leur
rentabilité et de protéger leurs propres
intérêts et leurs propres intérêts ce ne
sont pas du tout les intérêts des
salariés de fiat et de psa et à psa on a
eu cette expérience malheureuse
concernant le rachat d'opel par par psa
carlos tavares s'était engagé à ne pas
fermer d'usiné certes il n'a pas fermer
d'usiné mais il a supprimé des milliers
d'emplois en allemagne en pologne en
angleterre dans les usines opel/vauxhall
donc c'est vrai que cette promesse c'est
vraiment qu'une promesse et les patrons
savent très bien supprimé des milliers
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois sans
avoir à fermer des usines
maintenant la crise sanitaire et le
break site
je pense ça va être de très bons
prétextes
mine de rien qui tombe à pic pour donner
des prétextes pour pour carlos tavares y
compris sans doute de fermer des usines
on ne sait pas encore dans quel pays
mais c'est évident que ce souci
d'augmenter sa rentabilité sa
compétitivité
ça va se faire sur le dos de l'ensemble
des salariés dans le même temps les
directions à 10 voilà c'était une
question de survie en père c'était ça ou
d'une certaine manière on disparaissait
dont disparaissez dans un marché très
concurrentiel et très compliqué en ce
moment vous n'avez pas l'impression ce
soir plutôt d'avoir sauvé notre peau
finalement sauvé la peau de l'entreprise
et des salariés qui vont avec
dans pour qu'on sauve notre peau il va
falloir qu'on se bat
vous savez ça fait des années et des
années que psa accumule engrange des
milliards sur milliards pas des records
financiers historiques chaque année et
pourtant il ya eu trente mille
suppressions d'emplois en france trente
mille suppressions de cdi en france
alors certes nous sommes dans une crise
économique extrêmement profonde
les actionnaires de psa de fiat fond de
calculs que en subissant ils vont
pouvoir protéger leurs intérêts et comme
le dit si bien carlos tavares une phrase
qui qui tourne dans toutes les usines
quand il va faire son tour de son tour
des usines
il va falloir aller manger dans la
gamelle des autres ça veut dire que les
actionnaires aujourd'hui sont en guerre
les constructeurs sont en guerre
économique entre eux et cette guerre
elle se fait sur le dos des salariés
avec la peau des salariés et c'est pas
parce que les intérêts des actionnaires
vont être protégés vont être mieux
protégés dans cette fusion que les
salariés vont en sortir vainqueur au
contraire on va avoir à faire face à d à
des plans de suppressions d'emplois à
des attaques sur notre pouvoir d'achat
pour réduire le droit collectif et par
delà les frontières
les salariés doivent absolument avoir
conscience qu'ils ont des intérêts
communs à défendre conçoit un salarié
qui travaille aux états unis en italie
en france en allemagne en espagne en
angleterre
nous sommes maintenant tous liés par le
même patron qui va falloir combattre
est-ce que vous avez déjà pris contact
justement avec ses autres centrales
américaines italiennes
ce que vous avez des points d'accord
vous sentez peut-être des différences
culturelles notamment avec les
américains qui n'ont pas forcément la
même façon de ne fonctionner que nous
bien sûr alors on avait déjà pris
contact avec les allemands avec la le
rachat d'opel par psa c'est sûr qu'il
s'est décidé au fis qui sont très
différentes des philosophies syndicale
très différentes on a pris déjà contact
avec les syndicats américains les
syndicats italiens dont nous sommes nous
la cgt le le plus proche
il est il est certain que il va falloir
créer des ponts des passerelles prendre
contact discuter pour un autre sens
défendre cette idée principale que nous
allons devoir nous battre et nous unir
par delà les frontières
l'objectif la politique des actionnaires
représentés par carlos tavares va être
de mettre en concurrence les usines les
unes contre les autres les travailleurs
les uns contre les autres les
travailleurs allemands contre les
travailleurs américains seuls les
français contre les espagnols etc
et ça c'est vraiment une politique qu'il
faut combattre une politique de division
parce que là dedans dans cette politique
les travailleurs ont tout à perdre donc
il faut absolument oui qu'on défend de
cette idée d'unité par delà les
frontières
en fait on est tous des camarades on est
tous des frères eux sont-ils justement
aussi inquiet que vous sur sur l'emploi
que ça soit les italiens ou les
américains
les italiens oui ils sont très propres
et codip peu près préoccupé excusez-moi
jeu 2-2 vaudois dans les jours à venir
avoir une discussion avec avec les
syndicats italiens
il est certain que la situation de fiat
les actionnaires de fiat la famille
agnelli en fait toute une affaire que
ils sont ils sont en déficit
tout ça c'est des il prépare les
réactionnaires prépare le terrain pour
mieux faire passer mieux faire accepter
tenter de faire accepter de justifier
des plans de suppressions d'emplois qui
sont inacceptables
en temps de crise économique on ne doit
pas supprimer le moindre en quoi qu'il
soit en cdi ou intérimaires donc il ya
des grandes batailles qui vont devoir se
jouer qui vont devoir se mener
et pour ça il faut qu'on prenne
contact il faut qu'on discute il faut
qu'on prenne conscience qu'on a des
intérêts communs à mener contre nos
actionnaires aujourd'hui tellement ça
sera ma dernière question qu'est-ce que
ça va changer pour les salariés par
exemple en france tout de suite
immédiatement pas grand chose à court
terme extrêmement rapidement sans doute
sans doute certaines choses des
suppressions d'emplois on l'a on l'a
vécu avec le rachat d'opel par psa ou
une partie de la r&d a été détruite en
france où carlos tavares a continué son
plan de suppression d'emplois là avec
fiat c'est pas un doublon qu'on va avoir
c'est un triple au ps à opel fiat là
dedans il va y avoir une politique de
chaise musicale et ça va toucher les
salariés qui travaillent en france
aujourd'hui aucune catégorie
professionnelle ne peut se sentir
protégé aucun travailleur ne peut se
doit se sentir protégé merci beaucoup
jean pierre mercier délégué syndical
central cgt chez psa porte parole de
lutte ouvrière merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france